also ich hab sie cool man in viele
treffer crashte life skills und hatte
willkommen zu einer neuen folge
minecraft wir spielen heute einen
nagelneuen spielmodus der heißt in time
base dem gleichnamigen film in time
nachempfunden und zeit ist die währung
machen das zusammen mit dem wenig
hallo man startet am anfang mit zehn
minuten zeit die dann abläuft
man kauft sich für zeit waffen rüstung
food items und es ist richtig richtig
richtig nice das spiel das ist echt gut
gemacht macht richtig bock und ja es
geht gleich los in 10 sekunden hier
vorne sind die ville job bei dem man
zeigt auf wir müssen zusehen dass wir
ein schwert kaufen
dass am anfang das wichtigste wir
spielen übrigens mit meinem alten
texture pack da das kramer weggebissen
probleme macht ok wenn alex sehr gut
sehr gut
so werden schon 20.000 aufnahme versuche
weil ganz ganz viele nvidia crashs mit
dem alten pack dann pech alles mögliche
übrigens die grace period wird mit einem
gewissen item beendet kletterfans ist
nix dollar ist aber am anfang noch gar
nicht nichts war ein bisschen pech
meine lehrer pension hin okay die grill
wurde beendet weil jemand die time
keeper alarmiert hat es liegt aber es
kommt noch ein hinter bruder ein held
noch da müsste ich auch wenn sie ein
bisschen zeit wenn einer wenn ein
spieler stirbt wird seine zeit auf alle
verbleibenden spieler aufgeteilt
das ist richtig und der deckung geht
gleich dauern hier komm schon okay ist
da vorne ist noch einer wir geben auf
den drauf gucken muss der hat der
marokko ist einfach vielleicht können
überraschen
erst mal gucken ob seine rüstung gibt
royal rangers mit dir hoffentlich wird
das nicht eine minute eine minute eine
minute zeit habe ich noch jetzt hat er
mich gesehen was mir gekauft habt und
rennt weg knapp alter ist das gras mann
hatte hier geht's bisschen zu dick muss
mir ein bisschen früh kaufen unbedingt
mal eine waffe ich hab richtig gutes
skript aber keine waffe also bevor ist
im halterner ok hat sich versteckt es
war nicht so schlau von ihm chip chips
jam session problem wer noch 240
sekunden zeit gesetzter recht sollte
alter schwede wenn die 42 sekunden
ablaufen sind wir tot
es sei denn zwischenzeitlich steht auch
ein anderer spieler plus 42 sekunden ja
gott ist gestorben wichtig warum kriege
ich keine zeit so wenig gehört ihr nicht
mehr viel zeit
glaub ich und ich konnte wieder nicht
unbedingt was zu essen und gott oh gott
getötet 50 sekunden
alter schwede was ist los man dieses
spiel ist so ein adrenalinkick da auch
noch einer stirbt dankeschön geschenkt
hat gestimmt
eine minute zeit nach erhält er hätte
noch die ganze zeit mit zwei minuten
geraten sich immer noch keine waffe ich
komme nicht gleich muss trinken animiert
zu schauen
ich habe jetzt zwei alexis nicht ganz
gutes rüstungsexport richtig viele leute
deswegen wie wenn die zeit stirbt das
problem aber es ging es gerade in ein
ordentliches zubehör knapp 130 jetzt
hier der böse onkel gebe ein bisschen
rock pop shop und onkel ok 450 sekunden
wir müssen die mitte wir müssen die
mitte wo ist die mittel dafür drüben in
der mitte kann man nämlich zeit aufladen
leute glauben noch nicht aktiviert wurde
bisher nicht bin ich sicher glaub nicht
steht dann muss jetzt irgendeiner
sterben bitte stirb leute ich habe
keinen spaß ist es auslöst aber jetzt
gibt jetzt jetzt jetzt jetzt abgesehen
in der map mit liebe zeit verteilt
und wo ist die map mitte und es ist eine
gestorben nicht schlecht aber davon ist
die werbemittel tabulaturen ist dagegen
jetzt mal hin und hoffe ich sehe sein im
waffen gilt aber ich komme ich an ihnen
dran steht auf dem horst in die
erreichen oder ja genau da vorne ist auf
jeden fall ein dank ärgerlich wenn der
täter den hohen umsätzen holen wir uns
die attacke attacke reisen schwert gdg
da und gedacht ich hab mich da bin ich
hab ihn ich habe ihn jetzt keine zeit
mehr mit der zeit aufladen es sei denn
es kommt einer auffahrt alter kraft
überlebt magic anrainer ok irgendeiner
oder asiatisches du hast doch stets von
mir oder nicht ok auf jeden fall laden
wird derzeit auf nein nein
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] alter o mein gott ich hab
schon an der zeit gesehen weil du auf
einmal nicht mehr zeit aufgeladen haben
man lebt nämlich nur in der zeit auf in
der mitte wenn man alleine dasteht
jetzt habe ich meinen hut weggeworfen
alter schwede und zwei leute hinter mir
ich hab auch glaube ich mein ja ich hab
mein flug weggeworfen kirche mit der
waffe gekauft aber jetzt jetzt bei mir
auch nicht die knapp aus gibt es noch
eine minute alt da hektik hektik hektik
hektik hektik hektik hektik hektik
hekticket hektik hätte gott ich glaub
ich hab da einer von denen ist mord und
der will mich so ein bisschen beschützen
damit die aufnahme nicht scheiße wird
oder was du was okay denn auf den fall
geholt dem gebäude geholt
ich bin diesem kanal wie kennst du ja
und ich komme nicht mehr aus
ich hab keine zeit online times du
außerdem eine hier komm ich komm raus
alles gut man ich habe mich mein weg
geworfen das ist so ärgerlich
nein jetzt kann ich nicht sagen weil wir
bei der mit üblicher so überrascht hatte
gott ist bringt leute wie ich ein
problem wo ich gesagt man die eigens
anziehen
damit können wir zeit offline hier so
tack
kein falscher einkassieren recht wenig
leben so jetzt können wir ein bisschen
zeit aufwand und bitte vor gott ich kann
ich finde diesen kuchen muss man auch
online publik noch da die hier ist ca
jetzt muss ich aufpassen bauleute diese
runde
das ist eine meiner besten runden dieses
spiel macht einem ich so fertig das ist
so geil dass jemand wo beim kanal kommt
er unter
da kommen wir da hin oh oh oh ja komm
mach dein ding macht oder der linken ist
alles gut alles gut
hier kommt die fdp machte mein ding da
drüben ich stehe hier der mitte alter
schwede
ich muss erst ein bisschen zeit aufladen
in der mitte rechts läuft die zeit
nämlich rückwärts aber man wird auch
gerne gerne mal weg gekämmt oder
weggehauen weil alle die mitte wollen
natürlich hat ein blutbad mit nur
richtig viel zeit geklaut und sich seine
zeit wenn ich das machen ja da hat es
nicht mehr so viel und es laufe ich vor
dem bag besonderen zeiten eingestimmt
gute strategie ich muss eine minute
weglaufen ihr kind essen das kann ein
bisschen knapp werden erfolgen muss das
könnte in der tat ein problem werden
mal schauen ok irgendwie hatten server
verlassen dafür gab es bisschen zeit
noch mal ein schwert kräften
ich tanke jetzt ein bisschen zeit in der
mitte es ist so ein nervenkitzel leute
ist es unfassbar ich sag's viel zu oft
aber es ist einfach so
oh ja er ist stehen geblieben ich habe
trotzdem kein essen und mitsprinten
man kann nicht sterben man kann übrigens
auch anderen leuten zeit klauen
entweder indem man ja ich habe mein gott
ich habe ich habe mit der uhr angeklickt
na also auf mich zugelaufen ist mich zu
töten ja dass in der letzten zeit ist
dann gestorben nice alter richtig mein
gott man kann leute nämlich mit einem
mit einer uhr wenn man die links klickt
also schlägt mit der uhr kann man den
zeitplan oder mit zum zeitspeicher wenn
man den rechtsklick genau mit der uhr
zieht man zehn bis 15 sekunden ab je
nachdem ob man normalen schläge oder
tritte aber dem zeitspeicher kann man
richtig richtig viel zeit klauen
brauche ich bin mir nicht sicher aber
ich glaube wenn man die uhren steckt
dann zieht man mehr zeit ja aber ich
habe jetzt zwei uhren also ich hab
nämlich bewusst nicht decken kann und
ich habe jetzt zwei uhr jetzt will ich
das mal ausprobieren ich mache greife
aber ich habe nicht mehr so viel zeit
ist das problem nach einer minute
dreißig und schildert in der mitte das
denn hier raus treppen oder oh okay okay
da hat aber nicht so gutes equipment den
habe ich mir da es erneut
und es dauert und der tv ja danke alter
jetzt gibt nur drei leute dich hab sie
den gegner größer nicht und michael
braun junge bin mir nicht sicher ob ich
mir mehr zeit gehabt habe oder nicht
sie danke für deine unterstützung aber
jetzt muss irgendwann ist auch schluss
ist und ich mich richtig schlecht dass
ich jetzt angreifen
ich habe hat sie gut meinte etwa greift
dann hast du damit die runde gewonnen
hast du pont du stehst du stehst hier
noch warte warte ich versuche wieder
darauf zu kommen jetzt bist du raus
roman okay wie schön die runde gewonnen
damit irgendwie sie irgendwas stimmt
nicht mit diesem treiber was war eine
nächste runde
lasst gerne daumen nach oben da weil ich
das gefühl hatte ich versucht das
problem über hinzukriegen dass nvidia
die ganze crash sorry dafür steckt
weniger ab dessen der beschreibung wie
sieht uns wieder paul ryan macht's gut
und schau schau